par contre une fois au tir debout une
fois en tir couché ok l'épidémie et ces
restrictions ne les ont pas freiné
durant les confinements ses enfants ont
pu continuer le sport
cet après-midi la séance de biathlon une
activité physique adaptée à leur
surpoids
alors qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
pouvoir viser correctement au deuxième
tour va faut des moins courir et
exactement et reprendre son souffle
pendant qu'ils en tirent bien au delà
des efforts physiques réalisés ici ils
reprennent petit à petit confiance en
eux on leur demande d'aller à leurs
rites d'apprendre à gérer leur effort et
je crois que c'est ça vraiment
l'essentiel pour eux c'est d'apprendre à
gérer leurs efforts et de se dire ben
non à partir de cela ça va pas je me
sens pas bien donc du coup je me remets
un petit peu plus bas je marche plus
doucement je trottine plus doucement et
là ils sentent mieux et ici ils se
sentent capables de et dès l'instant où
ils se sentent capables de c'est là où
c'est vraiment bénéfique pour eux grâce
à une dérogation avec le dispositif
passeport forme ils sont restés en
mouvement contrairement à une grande
partie des jeunes activités
périscolaires interrompue au ps à
l'école limité à l'extérieur les moins
de 17 ans bouge - depuis le début de la
crise un constat dressé par faire un
professeur de sport leurs capacités
sportives sont en baisse au niveau du
cardio aussi on voit des élèves plus
fatigués plus rapidement qu'ils sont
incapables de d'avoir des efforts
intenses en classe et donc du coup moi
je ressens cette baisse très fortement
vit une situation qui alerte les
professionnels de santé inactivité
sédentarité ses habitudes quand elles
sont prises dès l'enfance ont un impact
sur la qualité de vie à l'âge adulte
la sédentarité et la peine plus à des
maladies chroniques qui pourrait arriver
comme le toit évidemment mais aussi des
maladies cardiovasculaires et le diabète
à la gêne par exemple les cancers
beaucoup de maladies chroniques
mon sont induites par l'inactivité
physique au quotidien et ça commence dès
l'enfance pour sensibiliser les plus
jeunes et renforcer leurs activités
le rôle de la famille est essentielle
ici les parents qui les accompagnent
s'engage pour un an
la première séance elle ne voulait pas
venir mais vraiment pas et puis
mais dès la première séance le justement
ça a accroché c'est pas elle n'a pas eu
l'impression qu'ils étaient un groupe
par groupe donc celui facile aussi un
pee wee elle s'est sentie proche des
autres des autres enfants
c'est vrai que le mien il n'était pas
fort du tout et bat depuis qui vient ici
avec ses copains maintenant c'est plus
le foot il a choisi vraiment ce qu'il
voulait faire c'est du foot du foot il
parle que de foot
on a constaté nous que pour les familles
d'enfants en surpoids qui avait pu se
mobiliser
c'est à dire organisées quotidiennement
une sortie à l'extérieur pour simplement
marcher aller jouer dehors avec son
enfant ont limité les dégâts
ces 50 dernières années les enfants de 7
à 18 ans ont perdu 25% de leur aptitude
physique une tendance accentuée par les
effets du confinement